sí
como mencionamos anteriormente podemos
usar los sistemas de partículas para
crear otras cosas además del agua se
pueden crear muchos otros efectos con
ellos por ejemplo fuegos artificiales
para conocer su funcionamiento empecemos
por lanzar unas cuantas partículas bajo
la influencia de la gravedad cuando
alcancen el punto más alto de su arco
explotan y crean otras partículas a
estas las llamamos partículas hijas
con este deslizador puedes modificar la
fuerza de la gravedad un valor grande
evitará que las partículas se lleven a
gran altura y un valor pequeño hace que
las partículas salgan volando fuera de
la pantalla observa que las partículas
hijas desaparecen después de un corto
tiempo a esto se le conoce como su
duración y con este deslizador podemos
modificarla
incrementaremos también la cantidad de
partículas y gas que podrán crearse
para obtener algo más creíble añadamos
un poco de aleatoriedad por ejemplo
añadamos un poco de variación aleatoria
a la velocidad de las partículas fijas
del ojo así está mejor ahora vayamos un
poco el ángulo al que son lanzadas las
partículas iniciales
muy bien se ve genial
en el siguiente ejercicio verás los
tipos de espectáculos de fuegos
artificiales que puedes crear
en la siguiente lección examinaremos más
de cerca la física que está detrás del
simulador de pelotas de ping pong lo
cual es necesario entender si quieres
programar tu propio simulador desde cero